the loadmaster must be meticulous to
simultaneously offload Precious Cargo
and keep the aircraft safe this Qatari
C-17 is bringing much needed aid for the
Libyan city of derna after the
devastating floods generators tents
toilets and Medicine are all in high
demand as tens of thousands have nowhere
to go after their homes and businesses
were Swept Away we have a new Supply
who cargos with the medical supply it's
a huge amount we're trying to cover the
needs as much as we can even though
there is too many needs you can see now
even still until today there is bodies
come out from the sea due to the floods
that's happening there is a body that is
under the sea a trail of Destruction
remains where used to be the creative
heart of Libya with its poets and
vibrant culture
since there have been protests by Angry
residents who are demanding answers
dharna is run by the Eastern government
as Libya remains one country with two
administrations authorities here have
cordoned off the disaster area amid
fears of contamination and spread of
diseases the Libyan red crescent says
there is still need for specialized
teams in equipment as a large part of
Darna now reeks of the stenge of death
now the the all the teams and the body
teams inside them or work to collect the
company from under the houses damaged
and there are heavies while 23 tons were
being offloaded from the first plane
under the Qatari 8 flight arrived a team
from cutter red crescent will stay
behind to assess and evaluate further
needs
to find that the water is valued and
most of the water will maybe we'll use
it now so we are afraid to enter another
disaster I hope no
the tragedy in the East has United Libya
which remains fractured since the 2011
Uprising which toppled Muammar Gaddafi
hundreds of tons of Aid has been sent to
Libya from all over the world
once the aid is offloaded it is going to
be taken to the city of dharna where
main roads remain off but there are
alternative routes available and it is
not just the qatriate we've seen
multiple other aircraft Landing here in
Benghazi as well now the question
remains and how this Aid is going to
help the people who remain in dhana to
rebuild themselves after a tsunami-like
flood
at the Benghazi Airfield